le premier point que je vois qu'elle
voudrait intervenir c'est le
renforcement des moyens de détection et
de caractérisation de la fraude
il s'agit d'abord sans doute une mesure
importante la création d'une police
fiscale au sein du ministère du budget
sous l'autorité d'un magistrat et qui
est complément de ce qui existe déjà
c'est à dire notamment la brigade qui
travaille au ministère de l'intérieur
ainsi la proximité avec la direction
générale des finances publiques et des
services d' enquêtes douanières
permettront j'en suis sûr aux magistrats
de pouvoir confier
s'il s'agit d'une fraude fiscale
caractérisé qu'il n'y a pas de connexion
en tout cas pas apparemment avec
d'autres grands délits de confier à des
spécialistes de la spécialité pour
parler comme godard cette compétence
particulière c'est entre 30 et 40 agents
qui seront sous l'autorité d'un
magistrat une nouvelle fois et qui
traitera purement de la fraude fiscale
et de son blanchiment et un travail
important de complément du travail de la
police nationale cette police fiscale et
donc l'article 1er de notre projet de
loi et je crois marque la volonté
particulière de bercy de travail et plus
fortement encore avec des moyens
supplémentaires des moyens d'ailleurs
qui seront ceux d'officier de police
judiciaire
la possibilité de procéder à des écoutes
téléphoniques impossible possibilité de
faire des interceptions de renseignement
de faire des filatures bref de
considérer que la fraude fiscale puisse
être considérée lorsqu'elle est
importante et caractérisées comme une
grande infraction pénale